Depuis l'entrée en guerre des États-Unis en 1941,
Hitler redoutait une invasion
sur les côtes Ouest de l'Europe
occupée par les Allemands.
Dès 1942, il s'était attelé à une tâche gigantesque,
construire un mur le long de l'Atlantique,
constitué d'un ensemble continu de fortifications
sur 6 000 km.
De la Norvège, à la frontière espagnole.
Même si les Allemands soupçonnaient
les Alliés de vouloir débarquer dans le Pas-de-Calais,
distant de 40 km seulement des côtes anglaises.
Les autorités allemandes avaient donc réquisitionné
des milliers d'hommes.
Travailleurs libres, requis du S.T.O.
Réfugiés juifs, prisonniers de guerre,
pour mener à bien cette construction délirante
qui nécessitera plus de 13 millions de tonnes de béton.
Décidément, en cette fin d'année 1943,
la forteresse Europe semble solidement
aux mains des Allemands.
Et en ce début 44, il ignore toujours quand
et où le débarquement se produira.
L'arrivée d'Eisenhower à Londres
a cependant confirmé Hitler
dans ses craintes d'une invasion à l'Ouest.
En 1942, il avait nommé maréchal
un de ses plus brillants généraux,
le populaire Erwin Rommel.
À la tête de l'afrika korps, le renard du désert
avait donné bien du mal aux Anglais.
C'est donc naturellement que le Führer charge
cet énergique guerrier
de renforcer encore les défenses
de la forteresse Europe.
Début 1944, Rommel est en France.
L'aviation nazie mobilisée en Allemagne
contre les bombardements alliés.
Il ne pourra guère l'utiliser en Normandie.
Tout se jouera donc à terre
et sur les plages qu'il juge mal protégées.
Ils désirent établir une ligne de défense
continue en comblant les trous
entre les points fortifiés.
Et parallèlement, le maréchal demande d'intensifier
le minage du littoral.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'une mine ?
Une goutte d'eau dans la mer,
en regard des 1 200 km de côtes françaises
qui s'étendent du Pas-de-Calais à la base
de la Basse Bretagne.
Si les Alliés sont unis et rassemblés en Angleterre,
Hitler est loin des opérations,
dans son QG de l'Est, près du front russe.
Pire. Fidèle à son habitude,
il divise pour mieux régner.
À l'Ouest, il a fractionné le commandement allemand
entre le maréchal von Runstedt,
chef de tout le front occidental
et le maréchal Rommel,
responsable des défenses côtières.
Or, les deux hommes sont en désaccord.
Runstedt veut garder ses divisions blindées
à l'intérieur des terres,
pour pouvoir faire converger toutes ses forces
vers les zones précises,
où auront débarqué les Alliés.
Rommel, lui, pense que l'aviation alliée paralysera
les mouvements de ses troupes.
Il veut donc déjà répartir les blindés
au plus près des rives,
pour rejeter l'ennemi à la mer sitôt débarqué.
Mais il n'obtient pas gain de cause.
Dès lors, il se concentre plus que jamais
sur la protection des plages
et dresse des obstacles antichars.
Il exige aussi l'installation de barrières anti-barges
et de chevaux de frise
constituée de morceaux de rail formant
de redoutables obstacles.
Il s'attaque même à la géographie du terrain
afin d'empêcher les parachutages alliés
et leurs mouvements de troupes.
Quand ils le peuvent, les Allemands inondent
l'intérieur des terres côtières.